no jaywalking on my watch you've heard
about speed traps but Anejo texas takes
highway robbery a step further when
Dayton a how police department officer
pulled over Ron Henderson for driving
more than a half mile in the left lane
without passing Henderson was on a
family vacation with his girlfriend and
her two sons they were heading to Linden
Texas Ron's hometown to visit family and
buy a used car got any drugs in this car
according to the police report and will
fit the profile for drug couriers since
they were traveling from Houston a known
point for distribution of illegal
narcotics to Lyndon a place known to
receive illegal narcotics the kids while
they were assumed to be decoys and
although the officer didn't find any
drugs he did find about six grand in
cash all the reason you deep cache drugs
the couple had two choices fork over
their cash and continue their vacation
or face felony charges for money
laundering and child endangerment in
which case they would go to jail and
their kids would be handed over to
foster care you called kids a calm drug
mules it may seem like extortion but
cash for freedom deals are more common
than you might think after their 2007
incident Henderson and his girlfriend
helped launch a class action lawsuit
against abusive civil asset forfeiture
laws which allow law enforcement to
shake down people and make money lots of
money I've seen this movie already it
was better with Jennifer Aniston in it
last year the Department of Justice
pulled in a record 4.2 billion dollars
from civil forfeitures officers may
swipe your property even if you're not
charged with a crime cops can drive the
cars they grabbed and seized cash has
even been funneled into officers
salaries now that's a funny movie this
is real life it ain't funny you filming
me you filming it pop but come on don't
cops have better things to do in 53
percent of violent crimes nationwide no
one is arrested let alone convicted so
even though it isn't as luke hard -
busting people for drug offences only
sites could spend less time hunting down
cash and cars I moral I'm busting
murders and rapists love that ass
she's still got followed the show on
Twitter submit your nominees for next
month and check out Robert B host of
dead wrong radio and this month's
featured follower thinks it's a big shot
with Twitter in me are you twittering me
you